♪
>> TONIGHT WE ARE CONTINUING TO
REMEMBER THE AMERICAN HEROES
LOST IN LAST WEEK'S TERROR
ATTACK AT THE INTERNATIONAL
AIRPORT IN KABUL.
13 BRAVE MEN IN WOMEN FROM ALL
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AS YOUNG AS
20 YEARS OLD MADE THE ULTIMATE
SACRIFICE SERVING THEIR COUNTRY
WITH HENRI, BRAVERY, DISTINCTION
.
WE HAVE AN ALL VOLUNTEER
MILITARY GRADE THOSE BRAVE SOUL
TAKE ON THE CHALLENGE.
THEY ARE THE NATIONAL TREASURE
THAT ROSE TO THE EQUATION,
REPRESENTED THE VERY BEST OUR
COUNTRY HAS TO OFFER.
QUITE FRANKLY, THEY DESERVE SO
MUCH BETTER THAN THIS, AND
BETTER THAN TO HAVE JOE BIDEN
LOOKED DOWN AND CHECKED HIS
WATCH DURING THE DIGNIFIED
TRANSFER OF REMAINS OVER THE
WEEKEND.
JOINED ME NOW, TO GOLDSTAR
FATHERS WHO LOST THEIR SONS IN
LAST WEEK'S ATTACK.
LET ME START WITH YOU, MARK, IF
I MAY BE A YOUR SON WAS SENT
BACK TO AFGHANISTAN TO ASSIST
WITH THE EVACUATION EFFORTS.
YOU SAID IT SOMETHING HE ALWAYS
WANTED TO DO.
OF NEVER SEEN A YOUNG MAN TRAIN
AS HARD AS HE DID TO BE THE BES
SOLDIER HE COULD BE.
HE WENT BACK JUST FOR THIS
MISSION.
EXPLAIN.
>> IS, HE DID.
FIRST, I JUST WANTED TO SAY THA
JARED HAS EXEMPLIFIED SO MUCH
THAT ANY MAN COULD EVER STRIVE
FOR AND MADE ME SO PROUD TO
WATCH HIM UNDERTAKE THIS
ENDEAVOR OF GOING INTO THE
MARINE CORPS.
HE COMPLETED HIS BOOT CAMP.
HE WENT TO JORDAN, WAS EXCITED
ABOUT THAT.
AND WAS CONSTANTLY LOOKING TO D
MORE AND WAS GIVEN THAT
OPPORTUNITY.
>> FIRST, I WANT TO SAY TO BOTH
OF YOU IF I MAY COME AS A PARENT
, NOBODY CAN UNDERSTAND
THE LOSS THAT BOTH OF YOU HAVE
GONE THROUGH.
I CAN'T IMAGINE THE PAIN THAT
BOTH OF YOU ARE LIVING THROUGH
AND I'M VERY SORRY ABOUT THAT.
MARK, YOU MET WITH BIDEN OVER
THE WEEKEND, HOW DID THAT GO?
>> INITIALLY, I WASN'T GOING TO
MEET WITH HIM, BUT THEN I FELT
OWED IT TO MASON TWO AT LEAST
HAVE SOME WORDS WITH HIM ABOUT
HOW I FELT, AND IT DIDN'T GO
WELL.
HE TALKED A BIT MORE ABOUT HIS
OWN SON THEN HE DID MY SON IN
THAT DIDN'T SIT WELL WITH ME.
>> YOUR SON WAS A HERO.
I CAN'T IMAGINE THE PAIN I
REALLY CAN'T.
HERE IN, YOU SAID YOUR SON HAD
THE BIGGEST HEART IN THE WORLD,
AND NO PARENT, AND AS A PARENT,
I THINK EVERY PARENT WATCHING
RIGHT NOW UNDERSTANDS THIS, NO
PARENT SHOULD HAVE TO BURY THEI
SONS OR DAUGHTER, IT'S NOT
SUPPOSED TO WORK THAT WAY.
HE WAS SCHEDULED TO RETURN HOME
ON SEPTEMBER 15TH AND RETIRE IN
MARRY HIS FIANCÉE, NICOLE.
I CAN'T IMAGINE HOW YOU'RE
FEELING TODAY.
>> IT'S THE ABSOLUTE WORST
FEELING IN THE WORLD.
HAVING THEM BE AWAY FOR SO LONG
AND DOING THE JOB THAT THEY ALL
LOVE, THERE IS NO DOUBT ABOUT IT
, BEING A MARINE TO THESE GUYS
IS EVERYTHING.
AND HAVING THIS HAPPEN TO THESE
HEROES.
EVERY ONE OF THEM IS A HERO.
EVERY LAST ONE OF THEM.
THEY DIED WITH HER BROTHERS IN
THEIR SISTERS RIGHT NEXT TO THEM
.
DOING EXACTLY WHAT THEY ALL
WANTED TO DO.
AND THAT IS DEFENDING THIS
COUNTRY.
>> AMERICA'S NATIONAL TREASURE,
THAT'S HOW I REFERRED TO THEM.
YOU CHOSE NOT TO MEET WITH
PRESIDENT AYDIN.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU WANT TO
COMMENT ON THAT.
WHEN I SAW BIDEN LOOK AT HIS
WATCH, I WAS LITERALLY LIKE
YOU'VE GOT TO BE KIDDING TO ME
BECAUSE ALL OF THIS WAS
PREVENTABLE, WE SAW THEM ON THE
MARCH, WE HAD APRIL, MAY, JUNE,
JULY, TO EXTRADITE EVERYBODY IN
OUR EQUIPMENT IN WE DIDN'T DO IT
.
WHY DID YOU CHOOSE NOT TO MEET
WITH THE PRESIDENT?
>> FOR EXACTLY THE REASONS YOU
JUST GAVE.
WE SAID ABSOLUTELY NOT.
WE DIDN'T WANT TO DEAL WITH THEM
, WE DIDN'T WANT TO WE
DIDN'T WANT HIM ANYWHERE NEAR US
.
WE AS A FAMILY DECIDED THAT THA
WAS THE WAY IT WAS GOING TO BE.
IN REFERENCE TO THE CHECKING OF
HIS WATCH, THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN
JUST ONCE.
IT HAPPENED ON EVERY SINGLE ONE
THAT CAME OUT OF THAT AIRPLANE.
OF THEM.
THEY WOULD RELEASE THE SALUTE,
AND HE WOULD LOOK DOWN AT HIS
WATCH ON EVERY LAST ONE, ALL 13
HE LOOKED DOWN AT HIS WATCH.
AS A FATHER, YOU KNOW, SEEING
THAT AS A DISRESPECT, AND
HEARING FROM HIS FORMER LEADERS
ONE OF HIS MASTER SERGEANT SAID
EXACTLY WHAT YOU JUST SAID, THA
THIS WAS AVOIDABLE, THAT THEY
LEFT THEM OVER THERE.
THEY LET THEM DOWN, WE CAN'T
HAVE THAT.
IT CAN'T HAPPEN EVER AGAIN.
>> WE ALSO ABANDONED AMERICANS.
AMERICANS NOW ARE ON THEIR OWN.
WE LEFT THEM BEHIND.
MARK, DO YOU WANT TO COMMENT ON
THE WATCH INCIDENT?
DID YOU NOTICE THE SAME THING?
>> IS, I DID.
I LEANED INTO MY SON'S MOTHER'S
EAR IN I SAID I SWEAR TO GOD IF
HE CHECKS HIS WATCH ONE MORE
TIME AND THAT WAS PROBABLY ONLY
FOUR TIMES IN, I COULDN'T LOOK
AT HIM ANYMORE AFTER THAT.
CONSIDERING THE TIME AND WHY WE
WERE THERE, I FOUND IT TO BE TH
MOST DISRESPECTFUL THING I'D
EVER SEEN.
>> I KNOW THERE ARE NO WORDS
THAT ANY COMMENTATOR OR HOST
COULD EXPRESS THAT'S GOING TO
TAKE YOUR PAIN AWAY.
BUT I CAN TELL YOU THAT THIS
AUDIENCE SHARES IN YOUR ANGER,
AND SHARES IN A DEEP
APPRECIATION IN THANKFULNESS IN
SADNESS AT AN UNNECESSARY LOSS
OF LIFE IN THIS CASE.
WE WILL BE PRAYING FOR ALL OF
YOU IN YOUR FAMILIES, THESE
INCREDIBLE YOUNG MEN THAT YOU
RAISED THAT MADE THIS COUNTRY
THE GREATEST COUNTRY ON EARTH.
THERE ARE SOME LEADERS THEY
DON'T MAKE THE COUNTRY GREAT,
BUT THEY DID.